all right tyrone hey how you doing
great great uh welcome back thank you
so your last talk here was uh we talked
about the boogie man you know
and he got stands i guess you can say i
really wanted to be part of and want to
be liked
you know i mean i got so much attention
from the boogie man you know it's just
it kind of
kind of felt good you know and
and when you're a kid you need that
attention was it was it
kind of a replacement for the what you
weren't getting from your dad right it
was a replacement
it was a placement because i wanted i
wanted to be
part of i wanted to be like you know
when when they wh when you do when you
make mistakes from your kid
you know people tell you you ain't gonna
be nothing
you ain't gonna be [ __ ] you don't see it
oh oh oh oh
oh god gonna punish you i mean yeah i
mean
i mean you put in fear i had fear
i had a lot of fear you know i mean i
was the only child for a long time
you know what i'm saying for a long time
with the only child
and when this man and we said
my so-called brother i didn't know was
my brother because my father
for my father's first marriage he was
sticking around and like i said i found
that out later
that he was giving me so much attention
it's like
i ended up liking it you know what i'm
saying and
plus i was the only child you know i
mean for a long time
and i needed that attention man and i
enjoyed it
as time went back well it sounded like
you had very little guidance very little
i was lost role models yeah i was lost
i was really lost and
as i got older i still wanted that
attention you know i wanted to be liked
i wanted to be a part of you know what
i'm saying but i have so much pain
and and i tried to hide the pain and i
still try to hide it today
you know uh i dress up the outside
but the inside is hurtful do you use any
i mean i drink i do drugs
um just to kill the pain i got a lot of
pain
and and when you
you got to understand when you are
conditioned a certain way
you know it's hard to recondition
yourself because you've been that way so
long
you know and it's a part of me
it's a formative years yeah i mean how
can i i've been conditioned
i'm 54 i've been conditioned
50-something years and all of a sudden i
try to recondition myself
two or three weeks or a month that 50
that 50 something years is much stronger
you don't see anything in months or
weeks and it's gonna come
right back because it's so normal to me
you know what i'm saying i enjoy
i enjoy pain it's a part of me i enjoy i
enjoy
i enjoy being hurt i enjoy that because
something don't happen actually
about when i was a kid
if if you didn't yell at me or
a golf on me or trip on me i think it
was something wrong
like man i mean you ain't you know what
i'm saying you ain't dead you ain't
holding me in a while
you know what i'm saying that's how
women end up with abusive boyfriends
over and over again because it becomes a
party
you know and i didn't i didn't i didn't
understand a lot of things when i was a
kid because
you know i tried to pay attention see
when i used to go to go out with moms
and pops
they had their little parties i couldn't
hang out with my cousins because they
was too old
so i had to stay home with the old
people
while they was doing their drinking and
dancing and my only friend was princess
that was the dog me and the dog hung out
a lot
but i should sneak and get the beers i
just drink old style
in chicago they used to have old stuff
so i just go in the refrigerator
and drink the beers sneak while they're
in there drink it i mean drunk playing
cards and i would get princess on the
dogs so me and me and the dog were
drinking have fun
i hung out with the dog you know what
i'm saying because i was too young to
have
my cousin they wouldn't they wouldn't
take me anywhere they want to take me
so when they left out no people had
their little parties and played cards
and drinking and
smoking they herbed in i had to go in
the back with the dog
but i would sneak in later because and
this would happen every week
so i was becoming conditioning myself
again
to cure the pain so that was one thing i
was killing the pain
you know i first started smoking herb
when i was 10 years old in fifth grade i
used to have a friend of mine mother
used to give us weed
every day at school but we had to come
to a house we had to go to this house
and smoke it upstairs and we shot
basketball in that in the backyard
and i and i've been drinking before then
because hanging out
at the little parties with pop mom pops
at their little party so i was drinking
sneaking drinking beers anyway
and when i was a kid pops when i had
cold she used to give me a hearty tardy
he hardly thought it was whiskey at
limit and i enjoyed that
because it went down strong but it
killed the pain
so i used to sneak and drink the whiskey
crown roar raw crown whatever you call
that yeah
i remember that you know and
and the pain became so fun because when
i medicated
i enjoyed medicating it so i enjoyed the
pain
and i enjoyed medicating it
and and not just the way i grew up
you know i really grew up and as i was
growing up
i still wanted to be part of so i wanted
friends to like me
you know if you didn't like me i figured
something wrong
you know what i'm saying but i enjoyed
the pain
but i want to be liked part of
you know what i'm saying and
you know somebody told me i mean
if you want to be a doctor you can't
hang around doctors and do what doctors
do
and i remember when the person told me
that but i hung around
with people who abused me talk talk bad
to me
because that's what i wanted that's what
i enjoy
because if you didn't if you didn't do
that to me i feel what you're used to
that's why i was i'm conditioned that
way yeah
i feel something wrong if somebody loved
you and and respected you
when you were six years old you'd be a
different person you'd respond to
different things
always probably different thing but
since it wasn't like that and if you did
try to
if you didn't yell at me or didn't or
gave me some type of different
reaction i figured something wrong
because i enjoyed the action
the action which you had before became a
part of me
your condition i was conditioned that
way
and you know what i'm saying and when i
was growing up
and i should trip on pops like damn man
what's wrong with him man he tripping he
should tell me man
it ain't his fault because he's
conditioned that way
and that's how i was that's why i was
the condition that's how i learned that
word
when i was young because you stood on
like man
he said it ain't his fault
and as i got older and i never forgot
what he said about that person
so i clamped onto that it's not my fault
it's not my fault you know so
um and it's hard to recondition because
when you put that re in front of
condition it's action word
recon i enjoy being just the way i am
i enjoy the pain i mean man i'm four
years over half a century
you know you always too late to change
ah
you know they told me i learned that
it's hard to change but you have to
transform
just like a butterfly a caterpillar
turned into a butterfly you cannot go
back to
a caterpillar but
man chan i mean when you change you can
change back to what
and i transformed it's hard for me to
transform
so long after i've been something like
this just wait 50-something years so
if i if i try to change you gotta give
me another 50-something years to change
i don't want to leave before i change
at least i can match it up and compare
it but otherwise net
50 something years is too strong you
know
so you know we i'm gonna keep doing
keep living the way i'm living and by
the grace of god
and the mercy you know that
maybe he put people in my life at least
in my path
to help me here and there you know but
i'm still gonna stick around the same
people i stick around
i'm still gonna do the same thing i do
because
i enjoy it because i'm conditioned it's
what you're familiar with
a certain way yeah
i really be honest with you i really
don't want to change
you know i really you know somebody
if you had a chance to do it although
again would you do it different
no because if i do it all over again
it's going to happen the same way it
happened
that mean if i do it all over again
different people will have to be in my
life for me to be different yeah i think
the conditioning becomes so
powerful you can't even imagine growing
up with two loving parents
well i mean because what i wouldn't i
didn't you can't imagine you you would
reject it because it's too weird right
it's it's not familiar to me you know
and
that's why people have such a hard time
breaking out of these
because they're conditioned a certain
way yeah if they're abused as kids
they're going to recreate that yeah they
need to be abused when that's
the only kind of partner that will work
with them that that'll satisfy them is
somebody who
abused them and like i say
it's normal it's a normal it's normal to
them
it might be weird to you but
to a different individual but to me it's
normal
it's the way i live that's my life
and i i wouldn't be able to see any
different it's not your fault
it's not my fault i'm conditioned you
were you're
old when this was all going on oh six
years six five six years oh yeah what
are you supposed to do at that age you
know what [ __ ]
all you can do is go with the flow
because you
you're not strong enough and you know my
favorite character was
when i was a kid batman i really enjoyed
batman because he had all them toys
you know what i'm saying everybody
the guys i just the little friends out
here they like the superman
superman was alright he had a little
strong uh fastening string bullet and
all that throwing in a locomotive train
that's when we were kidding they say all
that
but i like the batman because he had so
many toys
batman she had this good girl you know
and it was it was
batman he was a thinker you know what
i'm saying
batman but she batman went through a lot
of [ __ ] too
a lot of stuff too excuse me a lot of
stuff
because him his parents they went they
they
kind of neglected him too
that's why he became batman you know
so all the stuff you went through as a
child that's formed you into the man you
are now
your your adult relationships do you
have a hard time
accepting love from others do you have a
hard time one word
people i mean the individuals that i i
be around
ain't trying to love you they're trying
to get something out to you
that's what you're you know that's what
that's what i like i mean
you know i mean ain't nobody down here
trying to love nobody
this is our own little community and we
stay in our community
excuse me we stand out come here now
you're on skid row just so everyone gets
rolled yeah
we stay we stay on skid row
nobody down here ain't trying i mean if
you might come down here with uh
some of these guys coming out with
girlfriends boyfriends this and that
but they don't love them because they
you see them out doing what they're
doing with other women other people
ain't nobody down here trying to love
nobody and that's what i enjoy
stay away from me i mean you get too
close to me i'm gone
i enjoy being by myself you know i enjoy
that
you know what i'm saying and when i come
around and
whatever pain i feel whatever
jive talking you talking you know what
i'm saying
it's it's it's cool and then when i want
to be by myself
because man sometimes i see i be by
myself i just cry
all of a sudden just start shedding the
tear and don't know why
because of the pain i'm tripping like
and so i want sometimes i'd be like
trying to see who see me
you know i might hear a certain song and
start
shedding a tear you know what i'm saying
because then i make sure i i leave
because
i don't want people thinking i'm weak
you know i mean words are
powerful see you know what i'm saying
sticking stone might break don't make my
bone but worth it never hurt me that's
jive
words are powerful they can make you
or it can break you you know what i'm
saying because you can talk
people can say so many words and you can
be hurt
or can say so many words and build you
up
so it can go both ways
so remember words are powerful
so don't forget that when you when you
have your kids your nephews and
don't tell them they ain't no good tell
me ain't gonna be nothing
please don't because it gets in their
head and it stays in their head
remember when they're kids they don't
forget about nothing they learn
from you they learn from you that's how
they look
how you think they learn hate uh or
raise uh
uh not like certain people you know i
mean
i brought a different color type
girl home before my parents came home
pops and went
off on me i mean tricked on me
you know i mean but man
it wasn't i'm cool with him you know
what i'm saying then
when he was in that house i had didn't
like have to like him you know what i'm
saying because that's the way he was
i think the importance of those first
five or ten years of a child's life
can't be underestimated because that's
the guidance
you know that sets the path for
everything they do forever here you're
50 years old
and you're you're still recreating what
you
what happened to you at six years yeah i
mean and i
ain't nothing and i do the same thing
yeah we all do there ain't no thing to
me
you know what i'm saying ain't like i'm
trying to get out of them trying to
i'm cool with it and life goes on
you know so hey man i appreciate me
you know let me come back and um
it's gonna be all right sooner or later
[Music]
it's gonna be all right just keep doing
what i'm doing
you're always welcome here tyler thank
you all right thank you
you